ovis Daimler is an actor but his
greatest passion is cars from his
childhood like this vodka org 312 which
dates back to 1967 Steimle was born in
Dresden and what was then communist East
Germany and he just loves the old East
German cars what's unusual about this
beautiful car he says is firstly the
two-tone paint and secondly that it was
already equipped with features for its
successor model v3 53 so it had
independent suspension and four coil
springs which one feel how they fit on
here at the back you have a wonderful
soft top and these plexiglass sides were
compromised because rounded glass
couldn't be imported from West Germany
they may not have given you a rosy view
of East Germany but at least a slightly
golden one which wasn't a bad thing
around here like its predecessors the
Varberg camper vehicle was only equipped
with a two-stroke engine which at least
put out 45 horsepower the 312 was based
on the original 311 von borcke a
three-digit number was used for all EMW
s and Bart Forks copying an old BMW
tradition and because that's ops it's a
real cultural Treasury says you can see
from the design these cars have a soul
to them and a certain smell it's like a
living being except the roof still opens
it's all quite easy he says you lie back
turn this handle and pull and you're a
step closer to heaven
insignia the bot port badging stretches
right across the front of the vehicle
there was an American representative
from Buick he said that vodka would only
sell in America if the name was written
on the front like with American cars so
that's what they did and they sold Stein
was other vintage car the Skoda falesha
convertible was even more rare in the
u.s. only one made it across the
Atlantic the 1961 model has a 1.1 litre
engine with 50 horsepower and reaches a
maximum speed of 130 kilometers an hour
in its day it was popular also with East
German actors style had one and so did
Angie Lee Kadam loser he says they were
great role models for me now I'm the
proud owner one myself
Phylicia means happiness and what about
Skoda Skoda means shame or pity he says
the man who founded the company in the
Czech Republic was German he needed a
Czech name so he took the German word
Shadow meaning what a pity and that was
translated to Skoda health checking on
the government as he possessed
who Vash Daimler believes the Felisha is
the closest that a real socialist state
could have got to building a flashy
convertible he takes his cars out as
often as possible reliving a piece of
German automotive history
you